bonsoir colonel Pierre De Jong bonsoir
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
êtes vice-président de l'Institut Thémis
spécialiste en géopolitique je le disais
on va essayer de comprendre ce qui se
passe sur le front mais également sur le
terrain diplomatique en franc en ce
moment avec une première question assez
simple après les Léopards Allemands les
challenges abritanniques les Abrahams
américains la France doit-elle oui ou
non livrée des chars de combat Leclerc à
l'Ukraine
alors que la guerre a un principe qui en
fait de comment dire de renforcer
l'armée ukrainienne on peut très bien le
concevoir donc tant que la France a déjà
fait des efforts très importants avec le
César avec des moyens entiers aériens
enfin qu'avec une série de batterie de
moyens extrêmement importante donc la
France participe à cet effort le
deuxième point c'est qu'aujourd'hui si
vous voulez la base ou le socle ou
l'assiette si vous voulez du nombre de
Leclerc disponibles et relativement
faible ce qu'on part sur une base de en
gros 200 Leclerc sachant que les 200
Leclerc il faisait une trentaine qui
sont jolies en reconstruction ou en
maintenance qui fait qu'il aurait 150
donc si on en prenait 10 ou 20 quel est
l'intérêt d'avoir dit souvent pourquoi
est-ce que 10 ou 20 c'est quoi c'est un
demi c'est deux escadron c'est même pas
un escadron et demi donc en fait ça se
passe significatif je pense qu'il faut
faire effort s'il y a des sujets plus je
dirais plus lourds d'autant que je pense
également que l'armée française elle
était assez réfractaire aujourd'hui
contenu de l'état de la menace est assez
réfractaire à donner ses engins c'est
les seuls engins lourds que nous ayons
parce qu'il y en a pas beaucoup moi
quand il y a une trentaine d'années il y
avait on avait 1500 char moyen enfin les
chars lourds d'aujourd'hui 1500
descendus à 200 on est contre le comment
dire le décrochage énorme et ça notre
armée le C nos militaires le savent et
je pense qu'il voit pas de la bonne oeil
de donner leur matériel de son chardon
50 ans rénovation vous l'avez dit ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que on a pas
les moyens aujourd'hui de fournir des
chars à l'Ukraine ben si on suivit des
dossiers de prendre à Pierre et donner à
Paul sur la même chose donc on peut en
prendre autant qu'on veut mais le
problème c'est que comme les usines de
construction des Leclerc sont arrêtés
depuis quelques années ça veut dire que
les engins qui vont être donnés ne
seront pas recomplétés et un char lourd
c'est pas rien vous savez qu'on
travaille avec fin le comment dire de
nos ingénieurs travaillent sur un modèle
de blindé mais c'est pour en 2040 donc
on en est pas du tout là donc c'est le
vrai sujet c'est aujourd'hui que c'est
quelque soit les mesures de remplacement
et là il y en a pas sur un compte qu'on
soit obligé d'acheter nous des léopards
dans quelques semaines ou dans quelques
mois pour remplacer nos Leclerc ce
serait vraiment un moment un peu trou
blanc quand même assez troublant vous le
disiez également il y a également cette
question si la France livre des chars
Leclerc à l'Ukraine a priori on
partirait sur une dizaine de chars 10 12
14 chars peut-être
est-ce que ça vaut le coup de fournir
ces chars là de créer une ligne
logistique spécifique seulement pour une
dizaine de chars bien sûr que non c'est
bien sûr que non dit Leclerc c'est même
pas c'est un gros gros escadron même pas
un escadron pendant une quinzaine si
vous voulez avec les problèmes de
maintenance au moins une quinzaine donc
c'est un escadron et l'escadron ça
change pas la face de la guerre par
contre du point de vue politique ça
c'est un regard qu'on peut également
avoir et on peut comprendre le chef de
l'État qui qui souhaite en tout cas qui
qui est poussé peut-être à adhérer à ce
mouvement généralisé c'est vrai que la
France elle peut pas continuer son
positionnement qu'on s'est de sécurité
ou ailleurs elle peut pas elle peut pas
ne pas participer d'une façon ou d'une
autre alors on a bien essayé avec les
amis du circées on voit bien qu'on a
fait une OP à l'envers on a essayé de
donner nos engins qui dans ton servait
de moins en moins et malheureusement
parce qu'ils sont ils sont trop légers
sont des bons engins moi je les connais
sont très bons engins mais ce sont des
engins légers et à roux et qui sont pas
du tout adaptés si vous voulez au
théâtre d'opération ukrainien ou là il y
a de la boue de la neige de la glace
évidemment leurs jeunes n'est pas
tellement adapté est-ce que la France de
par ces hésitations est-ce que c'est pas
aussi parce qu'elle a peur et bien de
renforcer cette colère de Vladimir
Poutine je ne crois pas alors ça oui
c'est bon parce que votre question est
elle est très bonne fin je trouve
vraiment intéressante mais je ne crois
pas du tout je pense que la France
aujourd'hui le Renault Macron ne se
situe pas du tout là on voit bien qu'il
veut il veut maintenir une espèce de de
tuyau de communication avec Moscou ce
qui est en fait je trouve plutôt bien
parce que c'est vrai que on peut pas
couper les ponts 20 jours ou l'autre on
a bien discuté je sais pas comment je
les ai pas où je sais pas avec qui mais
les vidéos faut maintenir ce lien mais
c'est vrai que je pense que que cette
démarche d'une démarche qui a lieu
actuellement si vous voulez elle est
complexes pour nous parce que notre
armée mais comme toutes les armées
européennes puis auproux on a été depuis
les années 90 on est sur un mouvement
descendant extrêmement important et nos
armées ont été totalement martyrisés en
terme de budget en terme d'effectif en
termes de mission en termes de structure
il serait donc c'est des armées qui sont
totalement orientées vers le combat
asymétrique la guerre asymétrique la
guerre en Afrique avec le corps
expéditionnaire
le 24 février si vous voulez il y a un
modèle totalement nouveau qui réapparaît
et là très clairement notre armée si
vous voulez malgré ses qualités
éminentes si vous voulez être en très
grande difficulté il faut réinventer un
modèle et c'est ça le l'objectif de la
loi de programmation militaire qui vient
d'être annoncé la semaine dernière à
partir de quand est-ce qu'on peut parler
de comédie gérance
j'ai des questions intéressantes écoutez
je pense qu'il faudrait demander un
Poutine quelque part pense qu'il y a que
lui qui va tracer une ligne je pense que
cette ligne elle est mobile en plus et
je pense qu'un jour il dira bah à partir
de maintenant vous êtes comme il est
gérant je pense il le dit déjà un petit
peu avec la livraison des chats anglais
allemand et américains je pense que les
avions seront un moment si vous voulez
les moyens qui permettront aux
Ukrainiens d'aller en Russie
Macron le moment si vous voulez d'une
forme de cobelligence quelque part
encore une fois je sais pas comment ça
va ça va le faire mais c'est vrai que
l'aviation ou l'initiale longue portée
de sur le high mars par exemple bien des
avions de chasse français ou d'autres ce
serait vraiment un signe extrêmement
défavorable envoyé en voyant russe mais
en même temps ça marque créer une forme
d'engagement extrêmement important donc
on voit qu'on peut considérer que si on
livre des avions il y aura un pas
extrêmement important qui se refait en
direction pas d'une combinaisance en
tout cas d'un soutien encore plus appuyé
qu'il ne l'est actuellement on va y
revenir que l'année pierre delongue mais
sur cette question des chars à nouveau
livrer des chars c'est une chose
qu'il soit ensuite opérationnel sur le
terrain s'en est une autre concrètement
comment ça marche combien de temps
combien de temps cela prendrait et cela
va prendre pour ce qui est des chars et
bien anglais allemand et américains qui
devraient être livré à l'Ukraine d'abord
tout dépend de l'organisme et les
américains ils ont déjà une mère à
traverser ou un océan à traverser ce qui
n'est pas le cas le cas alors prenons
les Léopards allemands par exemple voilà
ou même les Américains sur des bateaux
ça va arriver alors ça varie quelque
part globalement en Pologne je vois ça
comme ça et de Pologne ça peut partir
ailleurs par la voix par la voix par la
voix la voie ferrée c'est les voies
ferrées des camions des porte-chars vous
avez une deuxième porte d'entrée qui est
au dessin parce que il faudrait que les
bateaux remontent directement là je
pense que les bateaux avec des avec des
blindes à l'intérieur si vous voulez
monter sur des sacs contenus des
bombardements de cette semaine je pense
que les Russes fresque qu'il faut pour
détruire dans tout ça donc je pense que
vraiment ça passait par la Pologne ou la
Roumanie la Pologne par un port polonais
et ça descendrait par train en direction
en direction du front après vous auriez
une zone de regroupement alors j'imagine
que les poneys est frais extrêmement
l'intention dès lors que les blindés
vont rentrer en Ukraine parce
qu'évidemment tous les satellites russes
vont essayer de savoir où ça se passe
pour y mettre en place des mesures de
rétention donc si vous voulez on saura
pas exactement où est le où sont les
blindés ils sont par petits paquet au
dernier moment si vous voulez ils vont
se rassembler une forme de résoudre le
réseau si vous voulez et le réseau les
réseaux je dirais Ukrainiens se mettra
en place et ils vont foncer dans le tas
parce que le problème c'est que ces
engins ne fonctionnent que comme une
action de choc et donc ils ne peuvent
fonctionner ils sont efficaces que
lorsqu'ils sont regroupés ils forment de
concentration extrême donc s'il y avait
200 chars mais 200 chars seraient là
enfin il y aurait son chat en premier
richement et de son cher en première
version la bataille de Koursk 1940 en
1943 à 44 c'est 8000 chars pendant 12
jours pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
beaucoup plus c'est notre dimension bien
évidemment combien de temps cela va
prendre le tout dépend de la vitesse du
véhicule je dirais parce que je dis
facilement ce genre de choses le
problème tout dépend un du niveau de
motivation de la sortie si vous voulez
des hangars au mec les Américains
j'imagine que les verront pas les
Abrahams avant un certain temps en
octobre
sachant qu'ils sont des stocks colossaux
donc un truc comme ça on pourrait qu'on
considère que au niveau des Européens
pour les Léopards je pense que c'est
extrêmement rapide je pense que les
Ukrainiens les polonais ou les pays
limitrophes sont prêts de leurs engins
tout de suite ce qui veut dire que dans
les semaines qui viennent on pourrait
ces engins seraient sur le front sachant
que les problématiques liées à la
formation etc sont des problématiques
subalterne puisque à temps kyste
ukrainien il fait la guerre depuis 6
mois même sur un théâtre 80
enfin vous savez le niveau de motivation
etc par contre c'est là qu'on va la
grande différence par rapport aux avions
autant pour les pour les chars ça pose
pas trop de problèmes en quelques jours
on peut comment dire on peut recycler
attentiste par contre si on livre les
avions c'est un autre monde et là on
voit que si on devait livrer les avions
ce serait pas avant plusieurs années
dans un ou deux ans parce que vous
formez des gens des pilotes alors ça
c'est autre chose on est sur un autre
modèle combien de comment pardon va
s'organiser l'armée ukrainienne avec
tous ces renforts d'abord on imagine que
les chars vous dites un temps qui se
peut en gros s'adapter mais ils seront
utilisés sur des sur des zones de guerre
différentes
normalement non si vous voulez
en avoir très très peu parce que 200
c'est pas du tout c'est pas du tout
signification donc ils sont obligés de
les utiliser concentrés rappelez-vous la
guerre 39-45 les Français utilisaient
leur blindés on avait plus de blindés
que les Allemands on les on les a
utilisés et répartis sur le terrain ben
les Allemands ont concentré c'est la
théorie du cherpoint les Allemands
concentrés et là où ils sont concentrés
ils ont percé vous savez les trois
principes de la guerre il y en a pas 50
économie des moyens constatation des
forces et liberté d'action aujourd'hui
les Russes ont la liberté d'action ils
ont la concession des forces les
Ukrainiens ne l'ont pas et donc le
problème pour renverser ça c'est la
tactique pure et dure pour renverser ça
il faut créer un événement il faut
recréer de la défensive chez les Russes
et là il faut percer le front et là il y
a que les blindés qui peuvent le faire
et donc c'est concentration c'est pour
ça que je pense que l'affaire des 200
des 200 charges c'est un fusil et pas de
coups ça marche mais ça marche pas ça va
ils le font pas une deuxième fois est-ce
que ça sera suffisant l'Ukraine réclamé
300 chars on n'y est pas je pense que
même pour ascenseur ça suffit pas c'est
mon avis de de professionnel je leur
suis un peu maximaliste je dirais il en
faut au moins 500 parce que les pertes
vont être énormes et si vous voulez si
vous n'êtes pas si vous avez moins de
100 chats vous savez un régiment
français de char c'est 80 blindé par
exemple blindé ça fait un régiment c'est
80 chars dans un modèle avec 40 chars et
80 chars 80 chars c'est un gros régiment
on va dire oui ce que je veux dire ça
veut dire que 80 blindés donc c'est à
dire qu'avec les 200 blindés oui c'est
comme blindés qui vont arriver ils ont
en fait la valeur de deux régiments
c'est pas beaucoup vous savez que ça
vous on reverse pas le front donc les
Ukrainiens auront intérêt à ne pas se
tromper d'autant que deux autres
problèmes premier problème c'est les
conditions du terrain c'est que dans le
Nord si vous voulez on sait que les
terrains assez maracageux assez
compartimenté donc je vois pas très bien
c'est blindé s'engager dans les dans les
montagnes ou en tout cas dans le nord du
pays par contre dans le sud c'est
possible et le deuxième point c'est la
classe des ponts et qu'en fait le
problème c'est les engins qui pèsent 60
hommes pour le challenger le problème
c'est une classe de pont les ponts ont
été détruits donc il faut passer quelque
part et aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup
d'eau donc si vous engagez maintenant il
va y avoir la fonte des neiges donc il y
aura de l'eau partout donc les engins
peuvent fonctionner mais il y a de l'eau
partout donc on va couper les utiliser à
l'été et éventuellement au début de
l'automne après ça devient compliqué
donc si vous voulez le la période d'une
offensive ukrainienne elle est
extrêmement courte elle virait elle
commencera au mois de mai juin et elle
va terminer au mois de mois d'octobre
alors qu'il n'est pas encore il n'est
pas trop tard pour l'instant
aujourd'hui ils peuvent pas ce sont les
engins sont pas là donc ils vont pas y
aller
oui mais c'est comme ça c'est un constat
évidemment fallait faire avant mais en
même temps on a je pense qu'on a suivi
le demande du présidentiel inscrit il
demandait pas de blinder il y a quelques
temps d'autant que on était assez
réfractaire rappelez-vous il y a
quelques semaines on considérait les
chars comme des engins offensifs et qui
étaient et qui aurait pu troubler si
vous voulez le sommeil de Poutine
aujourd'hui on a dépassé ça compte tenu
d'un point et d'un seul c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les Ukrainiens sont en
très grande difficulté c'est ça le sujet
aujourd'hui si vous voulez les Russes
sont à la manœuvre c'est eux qui
avancent partout dans le don-basse et
c'est pas tous les ukrainiens et donc ça
c'est un la prise en compte de cette de
la menace et donc du risque potentiel
d'avoir des Russes qui qui progressent
et qui perce le front ils peuvent le
percer jusqu'où ils veulent quasiment et
ben ça c'est un risque majeur et je
pense que c'est pour ça que les pays de
l'OTAN aujourd'hui ben compensent avec
des moyens lourds colonel Pierre de dans
une guerre blindée mécanisée les chars
seuls ne suffisent pas les Occidentaux
ont déjà commencé à fournir des
équipements militaires est-ce qu'il ne
faut pas fournir également d'autres
d'autres équipements pour accompagner
une fois qu'ils seront opérationnels sur
le terrain vous savez c'est un coût
complet comme on dit donc c'est une
espèce de système d'armes il n'y a pas
que ça s'appelle un système d'armes le
système d'arme fait autour de l'arme qui
qui est le charme vous avez un
environnement avec des fantassins ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle le les armes de
mêlée c'est le combat c'est le combat
direct avec l'ennemi le deuxième point
sur les appuis donc il y a des appuis
d'artillerie extrêmement puissants parce
que le char va pas s'engager comme ça
donc vous avez une espèce de une espèce
de de rouleau compresseur avec avec des
avec des tirs d'artillerie et même et
puis également de la pub aérien ça c'est
le deuxième point troisième point il
faut consentir impérativement parce que
les Russes sont pas mal d'avions ils
sont pas beaucoup servi ils ont beaucoup
d'avions il faut qu'il y a un moyen qui
protège et donc avec des systèmes des
systèmes solaires donc qui vous avez
tout un environnement incroyable et ça
c'est pour la partie tactique et dès
lors que vous voyez le renseignement et
le commandement il faut des moyens
cryptés etc donc si vous voulez les
offensives de char aujourd'hui ça va
très vite il y a beaucoup d'informatique
il y a beaucoup de il y a beaucoup de
ferraille sur le champ de bataille et
donc évidemment ce sont des opérations
extrêmement lourdes à monter vous
parliez des offensives plus on a observé
ces temps-ci des avancées du côté de
zapporija on voit également qu'il y a la
bataille de bac Moutou une bataille très
très serrée les Ukrainiens eux alertent
sur une potentielle offensive au
printemps ou est-ce que cela pourrait se
faire selon vous difficile après dire
mais on dit pas la science de la guerre
on dit l'art de la guerre et ça c'est le
rôle du chef aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on
voit on voit que cette malheureusement
c'est vraiment une tension extrême c'est
que leur armée malheureusement ils sont
obligés aujourd'hui d'étaler leur armée
entre la Biélorussie et la mer Noire
donc sur les milliers de kilomètres là
vous avez tout c'est armée qui est
aligné là parce qu'ils sont en défensive
alors que les Russes sont en offensive
donc eux ils vont concentrer là où ils
veulent et qu'est-ce qu'ils font
aujourd'hui on voit bien ils mènent des
opérations de comment dire de
vérification de de l'état de l'état de
résistance de de l'Ukraine donc il en
fait dans le Nord à soledar ils vont
continuer et bien évidemment la partie
centrale qui leur dit ça Boris Jack et
là où on pourrait imaginer une offensive
ukrainienne bien évidemment les Russes
vont essayer de conquérir cet espace
pourquoi parce que vous avez le Nieppe à
ce moment là ils vont essayer de le
tenir et donc ils le tiennent puisque
ceux qui tiennent sa porridja et donc je
pense qu'ils vont massivement se mettre
en place sur sa borisia ou bien tendre
un piège parce qu'il y a ça aussi vous
tendez un piège vous laissez ça rentrer
vous préparez à disposition comme une
espèce de Nas vous laissez les
Ukrainiens à rentrer ça pourrait déjà
etc qui vont aller ensuite en direction
du don-basse ou en direction de la
Crimée et là vous avez préparé une
espèce de Nas dans lequel les forces si
vous voulez rentrer à l'intérieur et là
vous venez une contre-offensive massive
à partir du Nord principalement en
direction des flancs des flancs de
l'offensive ukrainienne donc si vous
voulez les Ukrainiens ils ont pas
conduire des moyens qu'ils ont alors ils
sont fortement motivés ils sont plutôt
agressifs mais le problème c'est que
encore une fois l'art de la guerre fait
que personne ne peut dire aujourd'hui ou
ça va se passer quoi qu'il en soit ils
ont besoin de soutien des accidents qui
livrent des munitions des armes depuis
presque un an et pourtant nos armées ne
sont pas inépuisables jusqu'où va aller
se soutien occidentaux est-ce que il va
continuer comme ça pendant des années
après ce qui est sur une question
budgétaire vous avez vu que le président
Macron a clairement orienté nos
industriels à développer à travailler
plus et davantage donc on peut imaginer
qu'il va y avoir une accélération des
processus de construction et de
fabrication d'ailleurs dans la LPM le
président afin de la loi de
programmation militaire le président n'a
pas n'a pas évoqué le titre de fait il
n'a pas dit densification massification
il a dit cohérence cohérence ça veut
dire qu'il y a 200000 hommes dans les
armées il n'aura pas 200 à 1000 demain
matin donc c'est pas un problème de
structure pas de problème d'hommes
aujourd'hui il va renforcer ce qui peut
renforcer dans la cyber de les moyens
entiers aériens et surtout dans les
stocks de munitions alors après il y a
des études faites sur le porte-avion et
sur l'avion du futur on voit bien que la
partie si vous voulez stockage la partie
stock est très importante vous savez
aujourd'hui il y a il y a des chiffres
qui tournent qui sont assez effrayants
dans le genre l'armée française c'est 80
km de front pendant trois semaines
beaucoup de messages dans le chat
colonel Pierre De Jong Christian Léon
Toussaint par exemple qui nous dit
personne ne s'est vraiment ce que veut
faire Vladimir Poutine personne tous se
demande la finalité
[Musique]
les diplomates et les gouverneurs du
monde entier se satisfaire
éventuellement des espèces de de guerre
froide chaude ou de guerres tiède si
vous voulez en Europe mais le problème
c'est quoi c'est que c'est une guerre
européenne on est vraiment sur un modèle
qui est un modèle qu'on n'a pas prévu du
tout ce qui va faire une chose donc en
fait il va falloir réformer notre armée
la restructurer la réorienter en
direction des steppes de l'Est avec des
notions de corps de bataille de Charlou
etc des notions qu'on avait commencé à
avoir disparaître progressivement les
Occidentaux en tout cas depuis le début
du conflit veut l'éviter tout risque
d'escalade avec avec Moscou est-ce que
les Occidentaux ne se sont pas et bien
malgré eux
lancé dans cet escalade avec cette
livraison de avec cette livraison de de
chars et surtout vous abordez un petit
peu cette question tout à l'heure pardon
si les chars ne permettent pas de faire
la différence qu'elle pourrait être la
prochaine étape alors je peux pas vous
répondre parce que bien évidemment
ce que je veux dire c'est que encore une
fois je considère que 200 chars ça
suffit pas donc c'est un fusil à un coup
ça le premier point ça peut fonctionner
c'est un fusil un coup le deuxième point
l'étape suivante c'est quoi parce que le
problème c'est que pourquoi on donne des
charges parce que si les Russes si les
Ukrainiens avaient été black boulets
comme on dit il savait en fait avait été
rejeté à la mer comme dit l'autre etc
ben on va laisser les Russes arriver sur
la frontière polonaise bien évidemment
que non donc on voit bien que dans les
rapports de force on a évalué on a
compris qu'il y avait un risque
potentiel que les Ukrainiens reculent
premier point deuxième point c'est côté
de reculer c'est pas impensable tant que
le temps que les chars arrivent sur mes
6 mois pour le livrer les blindés et
encore une fois de son char c'est pas
c'est pas 1000 km de front c'est
quelques quelques dizaines de kilomètres
donc c'est pas beaucoup donc le problème
l'étape suivante c'est ce qu'a demandé
zaventki il a dit très clairement hier
et avant-hier il a demandé des moyens
des missiles des missiles à longue
portée on peut tirer pro le monde c'est
reçu à la Russie évidemment des moyens
aériens parce que aujourd'hui le moyen
permet aussi de tirer un missile de
croisière je dirais à 200 km ou à 150 km
ce qui veut dire que le l'angien il
décolle il se met quelque part il se met
à 200 km donc en fait il est loin du
front mais vous pouvez tirer sur des
étudiants des cibles et moi j'estime que
les U bien évidemment malgré le fait
qu'il le déni qu'il dise que c'est ils
vont pas le faire bien évidemment ils
vont essayer de le faire et pourquoi
c'est comme incroyable qu'un pays
attaqué ne puisse pas attaquer
l'attaquant on est sur un modèle
tactique et extrêmement étrange mais
bien évidemment donc l'étape suivante
c'est des moyens plus lourds et cetera
et cetera sachant qu'il y a une
troisième période c'est les hommes du
coup au bout d'un moment mais je dis une
fois que si ça fonctionne pas tout ça
est-ce qu'on finira par envoyer des
hommes et leur faire traverser la
frontière d'une façon d'une autre et ça
c'est un sujet et pour lequel je n'ai
absolument pas la réponse bien
évidemment énormément de questions en
tous les cas qui se posent merci
beaucoup colonel Pierre Delong pour
votre précieuse analyse je rappelle que
vous êtes vice-président de l'Institut
Thémis et spécialiste en géopolitique
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir